there is no returning to pre-pandemic
economy here we go again all right so
ap news federal reserve chairman jerome
powell said tuesday that the u.s economy
has permanently changed by the cover
pandemic and it's important that the
central bank adapt to those changes
those changes range from the increase in
remote work to restaurants offering more
takeout meals to real estate agents
learning how to show homes virtually he
noted many companies have already made
large investments in technology to adapt
to the challenges that the pandemic has
presented powell said the heavy
investment by companies and new
technology means that there will be more
jobs in the future associated with
maintaining that technology but also
potential job losses and industries
focus on in-person contact it seems a
near certainty that there will be
substantially more remote work going
forward
that's going to change the nature of
work and the way work gets done do you
agree no i don't and i think this is a
fad a cycle that we're going through i
don't think we can sustain the fact of
not going to the office i also you know
where's a little optimism where's a
little hope coming from our leaders
saying hey you know what we're on the
verge of this pandemic becoming an
endemic okay where we're going to be
able to live with it we're not going to
die we're going to survive you i i just
don't like the the messaging and i think
eventually once we pass
you know this cycle we're going through
with high inflation and maybe we get
some different leadership in there but
no don't make broad statements like that
when we just don't know
yeah interesting man um we kind of went
through something like this already with
the industrial revolution where society
kind of uh sat stratified itself into
urban and agrarian you know and then it
kind of happened again after uh world
war ii when you had urban and suburban
and it's going to happen again now there
are people that are genuinely hate being
around other people that love working at
home that love
wearing masks and not having any human
interaction and it's going to be very
difficult for them to come back into
society they don't want to they never
wanted to and then there's other people
like myself who i need to be around
other people i have to be in social
environments i go nuts when i'm not and
and i i realized about my that about
myself in the last 18 months i'm a very
tribal guy i need to be part of part of
a crew and you're going to have people
that are doing that you're going to have
people that are going to find
environments where you have to be social
and they're going to be able to find
environments where they don't want to be
social but i also say look this is the
obama doctrine also when they're talking
about the economy it's more than just
the functionality of it i mean they they
tell you we're gonna build back better
they've been straight up the world
economic forum has straight up told you
you will own nothing and be happy and
part of that that that that
fine print that you're talking about
what they didn't tell us is that it's
because they're gonna own everything 3.5
trillion dollars in stimulus already the
greatest theft in the history of the
world they took 3.5 trillion of the
taxpayer dollars and made it their
dollars and what did we get for that
1200 bucks maybe some of us got 1200
bucks for 3.5 trillion then they're
gonna get another trillion
only if we give them 3.5 trillion on top
of that so they already got four
trillion they're gonna get four and a
half trillion this is on top of the
eight years of quantitative easing from
obama the dollar is basically worthless
compared to was 10 years ago and all of
that money is now their money they
figured out a way to make the entire
world sick and the way to heal everybody
it turns out was to make all of our
money their money brilliant kai what do
you think about what powell said
i mean i think it's interesting uh it's
more of a long-term effect as well if
you look at kind of how things have
changed uh i think was you yuval harari
that said initially we read an article
back when we were still in dallas of how
a tremendous amount of change has
happened in a very short amount of time
uh and a lot of that can't necessarily
be reversed so i think there's
definitely more
uh long-term effects of this of what
what initially bounces back and then
trends or habits that have been changed
indefinitely uh so i think that'll kind
of play a big part as well moving on as
we go but then you also have uh like we
saw in the other article where retail
spending back to school is higher than
it's been uh the last few years so
there's kind of things that are
contradicting but i mean we'll kind of
see how things play out yeah like you
know you know it's crazy when when
you're saying this so okay
remember when everybody about newspapers
how long ago was that
15 years 15 years ago guys when we
bought newspaper remember when everybody
at their house had a photo album how
long ago was that yeah
landline vote no when's the last time we
had actually photo albums at the house
again
my parents 15 years ago 20 years ago
right now when's the last time we had
landlines how long was that 10 12 years
by the way if we did the percentage like
if i could pull up the data to find out
how many people don't have a home phone
that they use minutes i would love to
see the stats of minutes used on your
home on your home phone 20 years ago 30
years ago two minutes being used
in the office i have to have it is there
a hard line here in the office on the
office do we have a hardline phone here
or no
yeah we do we actually do we actually do
but but if you ask me how many minutes
i've spoken to my home phone matter of
fact
when is the last time you spoke on a
home phone
years
i haven't had one in 10 years kai when's
the last time we spoke on home phone
think about that 10 years how about when
you used to say i have to take this call
it's long distance yeah oh dude what
about when the the chord came out when
the extending chord came out you could
actually what about the call into this
like do you even have cabling so what
i'm trying to say is there's a part of
what he's saying is true like
some industries are going to change flat
out here's what we know we had sebastian
monasco at the event last week i'm
backstage and i'm having a conversation
together and i said hey sebastian how's
it been for you he says well i've been
doing a lot of zooms
i said house it's very different it's
very weird just get out there and you're
trying to make people laugh but you need
a reaction you're not really getting it
but it is what it is we're doing it
people want to do it and it's just like
a conversation that we have with them
what's this
u.s
household uh telephone i'd want to go 20
more years back but that's interesting
right there from 2010
to 2016. look at that shift right there
68.2 29.7 to 50.8 45.9 but going back to
it some industries you have to be around
people are restaurants going to go out
of business no
not go out of business are they going to
be going away no i want to go to dinner
i want to go have a sit down have a
conversation with you right is there
going to be an opportunity disrupt it
yes are movie theaters going to go away
yes if you kind of try to do the same
we've been doing it for 20 years so i
think there's going to be a lot of
disruption that takes place but i also
think some industries
are going to
take a hit like you know the whole story
with 70 percent of fortune 500 companies
from 1960 are no longer around today yes
of course because today i send this a
tweet i don't know if i posted a tweet
yesterday or not
where i said things are changing so fast
the ability to adapt and be able to
predict how
human behavior is going to react to
something in the next 12-18 months
that's the formula
so so
how is how are we going to react
to the covet if somebody could have
predicted that 12
how are we going to react to this
stimulus if somebody could have known
you would have made the right investment
it's all about being able to predict it
not a hundred percent but if somebody
can do that and make the adjustments
because things are changing very very
fast today now let's flip it are our
people
gonna want to be to themselves and not
be around people i can't see that
happening i i can't see your handshakes
you know when i go when i'm shaking
hands now they're like hey how are you
doing they do the album
but but you know what we know what you
see is a lot of people right now just
shake hands i'm seeing like especially
in florida maybe not in california
california's like don't even get close
to me but people are shaking hands true
how are you doing i was in indiana i
went there and when a guy comes up you
know the driver how you doing sir i'm
like oh i don't know you you don't know
that's cool shook his hands right so
some of the stuff i think
will go away but i think a lot of the
stuff that's the human interaction how
can a company thrive when people aren't
at the office especially big companies i
just think sure for a little while you
can adapt and make it happen but over
the long term i think people have to be
at the office by the way have you guys
seen the stories lately on the cottage
industry that's popped up lately with
people working from home it's people
holding two or three full-time jobs and
not letting the other companies know
about it having separate computers i
mean this is a big thing there's a big
online forum where people share ideas
and how they're getting away with it we
talk about that or no we haven't talked
about it on the add it to the story next
time yeah there are people that are
doing multiple full-time jobs and that's
why they want to stay working at home
and then how they dividing their time
and making changes
you know why it's not going to work long
term
how long can you run a
how long can a con man keep coming yeah
double life man you just can't do it so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]